good morning rich I'm gonna I'm gonna
start you with this one yeah I want you
to come up with a question that you
would ask Bill Belichick where you think
you would actually get a reasonable
response okay ask him a reason we
respond are cave on what can you at
least give me that just any omnibus
question is that what you're saying okay
let me let me play one and then tell me
if you would ask it in a different way
here's here's Bill Belichick and it's
Mike Reiss of the mothership asking
about here we go Super Bowls in the past
you guys haven't scored in the first
quarter how much do you look at that
history and this week and say you know
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
how like I ski you know like okay I go
up the mountain I'm thinking I'm just I
got it I got this I've got it I'm gonna
get off the chair i'ma get down there
and then all of a sudden Oh Mike Mike it
started out okay yeah and then okay
that's a very that's a very obtuse angle
right yes it that but we're all all of
us it's like again Dan is the 15th
Superbowl I'm covering for the NFL
Network New England's been an eighth of
them I mean so if you're constantly
covering the Patriots or the Patriots in
the Super Bowl you're you're fresh out
we're fresh out we're fresh out why
would you ask that question though of
they they haven't scored a touchdown
the first quarter many of their Super
Bowls but you can't do that you gotta so
what what are you looking for like what
answer your life were like hey yeah you
know we're gonna go to the film and I
noticed I did notice back in the Super
Bowl that we had against Houston you
know against Carolina in Houston that we
were inside the toilet like you can't
that that's not the way you go you need
to go macro with him you know you'd like
bill what are your memories of your
first Super Bowl with the Giants you're
you know you're making your now 17th
what was that your memory and how is the
game changed the Super Bowl it changed
since their last time you want it you've
got this great stat and you see that's
the problem is the reporter locks in on
a great stat which doesn't make it a
great question unless you say looking
back on all your Super Bowls yeah you
know what you got to get them to wax
rhapsodic if you can I mean you know ask
them ask them about you know Bavaro
right usual for LT you get them going
that way if you can but that that's just
you trying to help your fellow reporters
who are kind of I guess fill out a
column that they're or a story that
they're trying to figure out but you're
asking a guys that question and he's
famous for going up there and saying
stats are for losers
you know scoreboards for winners but
what about the growing town ski topic
here's a reporter asking about the
status of Rob Gronkowski can you give us
an update on Rob Gronkowski has he
finished his concussion protocol do you
expect him to play oh boy that's our
card we'll put it on when is that
process we'll put it on the injury
when they shared it first want to get
sure you well do you second a lot of
problem do you expect them to play we'll
put it right on the injury report and
that's what we're gonna do everybody
else does
I'll make sure you're first on the list
to say say can you tap out early it
where's the rest to stop the fight so
need we needed Mills Lane to get in
there and just wave off the rest of the
questioning yeah I mean cuz you first of
all you cannot ask bill a question about
injuries it's just I mean Tom Brady said
we'll see with a car on his hand
you know I mean please you're asking one
of the greatest competitors in the
history of the sport are you gonna play
you need he's got gloves on it both
hands like he's Inspector Gadget inside
you know I mean please obviously that
they were throwing you off the scent
otherwise they would have signed a third
quarterback right away if it was serious
so anyway you're if you're asking that
question is it devolved into asking
about actual paperwork how do you put
some paperwork coach I mean like me
through the process is there a piece of
paper that you write on and then you
snap it coach we have an idea though for
Super Bowl II and we think that every
reporter should just ask a question in a
Belichick Ian tone so you can just
mumble it to him bill then you talk
about Tom Brady's greatness here's the
question that we we here at my show and
also gameday morning we're kind of
locked up here if we had to ask
Belichick the one question you know he
won't answer and would actually Blanche
at the question would be coach if you
win your sixth championship so you're
already talking about something oh yeah
you got no shine there if you won your
sixth championship do
you think the Lombardi Trophy should be
renamed Isabella Schecter you think
that's one question he's not answerable
that know what I mean that's where I
mean outside of the usual procedural
question game question injury question
that you know he's not going to answer
but look coach you you are the moderate
you're being called the modern-day
Lombardi if you win a sick thing yeah
you'll break the tie with Papa Bear
Hallis that you're currently in you know
Lombardi won two Super Bowls and I
believe five NFL championships should be
do you think you we should rename the
trophy the Belichick trophy and see how
that goes we also wanted to throw the BS
flag here
here's Fletcher Cox of the Eagles
talking about his great suitable
memories from years watching the Super
Bowl as a fan is there any memory that
kind of sticks out these no I mean you
know I really don't watch football so
y'all know that
no I watch sports you know that you know
I don't watch sports
I tell you that all the time
artists it you believe that after no
after further review I do believe I saw
on Twitter today that he was caught
tweeting about the Malcom Butler
interception so that's that is BS there
are receipts and there are receipts that
shows I mean come on everybody watches
big football games that they're not in
what see what did anybody follow up by
asking what he's watching the crown on
Netflix and what is Fletcher Cox
watching what's he streaming yeah I
don't I don't know what what's he
binging there did you see where Vince
McMahon it's gonna start a new football
league yeah I'm kind of curious to see
what it is is it just a reboot of the
XFL when would it be who would it be
how much is he paying I mean all of that
as you know the XFL was one and done for
a good reason
so we'll see what is that later on today
right but what's the loophole where
where's the that that gray area or that
soft landing where if you did it where
is it going to be in the spring question
no idea it has to be it can't be up
against the the B NFL and let's not
forget also how college football has
truly kicked in to a much higher gear
than I think when he when the NFL
Network started in oh three college
football wasn't nearly as prevalent and
as possible now and to me that's part of
the reason why the ratings for some NFL
games certainly on Monday night
certainly on Thursday night are are
leveling off if not falling off because
college football has five windows on a
Saturday and if you're watching any of
them perhaps you won't have time or you
know in your family life to watch a
Sunday game or a Monday game so
Saturdays and Sundays are and Mondays
are kind of already taken Thursdays in
the fall so when would you do it up
against the NBA Playoffs yes Stanley Cup
I got I guess and I don't know where I
mean what facilities would you be able
to fill up it'll be interesting to see
obviously you got the money there's no
doubt about that
oh all right I'll see you I'll see you
next week yes
yes if we're next-door neighbor's next
week yeah I'd be playing appleís yes I'm
I'm very much looking forward to that
dance oh by the way kudos to the
production value of this interview Dan I
mean that was three sound bites if you
had ready cued up dropped in was it was
there a rundown for this that I didn't
get the rundown for this this interview
we did we actually had a pre-show
meeting and Seaton really yeah we had
pretty show meeting and seaton are you
gonna have a post-show meeting to see
how it all yes we'll have a post-show
by the way I hated those at ESPN I
absolutely hated those you'd get on it
like 2:00 in the morning and you'd have
a post-show meeting please make gather
everybody in the conference room and
they would go over the show the whole
one time I did our p.m. tonight
there was a post-show meeting for our
p.m. tonight now Mike what'd be 2:00
2:30 in the morning and you're falling
out of Bristol Connecticut you're going
yeah oh yeah all right I'll see you over
the weekend yeah but that's a Rich Eisen
from the NFL Network Rich Eisen show
coming up top of the arm for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]